it was billed as the last chance to stop
the worst ravages of climate change
but a watered-down agreement in
glasgow's left many wondering if it's
all too little too late this is the
great debate
[Applause]
we'll be getting to the heart of the
issue dominating the headlines this week
on the great debate the climate crisis
and whether the world has done enough to
slow it down
our viewers panel drawn from across the
country and beyond will share their
opinions they'll have their say
and they'll put their questions to our
studio guests
joining us this week cristiano fergueris
the un climate chief who delivered the
last global climate agreement
allegra stratton the prime minister's
spokeswoman on cop 26
the leading climate activist michaela
loach
and the former australian foreign
minister alexander downer
and a little later we'll also be joined
from los angeles by the film director
richard curtis
the big question
facing them all tonight
has the world done enough
or are we now facing runaway climate
change
a 2 degree world
means that a billion people will be
affected by extreme heat stress
we do not want that dreaded death
sentence
they're one of the lowest emitters of
carbon
emissions yet they are the country which
is really feeling the most impact
it seems like for world leaders nothing
matters for them it's corporates it's
business it's money
coal is so important to this area to
this community
india has fought successfully for that
change in the fossil fuel text
we can be immensely proud of what has
been achieved
today we rest and tomorrow we organize
again
right let's get on with it let's go to
the wall our viewers panel and i'm going
to start with
liz langfield i think you are in
newcastle liz
that's right trevor good evening good
evening
you've got to thought on this question
yes i have the i'm conscious how hard
everybody has worked who have been
delegates at the conference but i'm also
conscious that a lot of this
particularly from the uk appears to be
lip service we talk about our new oil
field our new coal fields and yet at the
same time we talk about climate
reduction and carbon reduction
we talk about
um
making environmental changes and that
doesn't seem to happen we talk about
planting trees but our
uh target has been 30 000 hectares per
year of tree planting one hectare is
about one football pitch
and that target has seldom been met and
we've got the same target going forward
oh 30 000 hectares of tree planting we
know that wetlands
capture a great deal of carbon from the
atmosphere and yet we are damaging our
wetlands with uh all this sewage that's
being allowed to
leak out into the sea it's being pumped
out into the sea four hundred thousand
liters gallons of the stuff was leaked
last year released into our waterways
and we now know that the mps have
decided there will not be any penalty
anymore for doing that
so my question is
are the cop26 commitments just like new
year's resolutions that will be broken
very quickly
thank you liz so let's come into studio
crack of a start
liz's question
are cop 26 commitments like new year's
resolutions that will be broken
very quickly
well
allegra
shall i just jump in thank you liz um i
think that they are new year's
resolutions from countries that have
already kept last year's new year's
resolutions and let me show you how the
uk has already liz um cut our our carbon
emissions at the same time as growing
the economy so on 1990 levels we cut
carbon emissions by 44
and the economy went up
by seven more than 75 so we we we have a
proven track record
um
the areas in which we were asking for
progress
on in glasgow coal cars cash and trees
were areas where we had already
demonstrated so for instance liz on coal
uh in 20 2012 sorry i'll just let me
just because it seems to be important
i won't let it clear up one thing but
finish what you're gonna say it's
important to liz that actually i show
her what we've done already rather than
what we're about so so on coal 2012 40
of our power generation now it's 1.5
percent and in 2024 goodbye no more coal
anyway i can tell i'm testing your
patience so i won't go through all the
others but the point is we've already
walked the walk and what we the united
kingdom presidency was trying to do in
glasgow was say in so many ways we've
already done it it is possible let's go
further okay i just wanted to get clear
because you said uh in that answer to to
liz that the economy had
gone up uh yeah by 75 percent and yeah
i'm sure that isn't quite what you meant
the economy we've managed to grow the
economy over the years at the same time
time has cut our carbon emissions oh
over years over years and i've said from
1990 levels so the point is it is
possible with the with the change in the
type of tech we are now using with solar
and with wind and so on it is possible
to do both things it is possible to see
economic growth at the same time as
change the way that you're you're
generating your power so we and all i'm
trying to say is we've already done it
that's why she should have confidence
okay michaela
you are
uh looking mildly skeptical
yeah incredibly skeptical i think that
it's um
i think it's false to say that the uk is
walking the walk that is just absolutely
not the case whilst the uk who say their
climate leaders are trying to approve
new coal mines in cumbria also are
trying to approve new oil and gas fields
um in the north sea none of this is what
a car like a climate leader would be
doing and i just i think it's completely
unfair to say that emissions have been
being decreased in the uk where now we
just export so many of our missions off
to other countries which then we blame
for the climate crisis the uk exports so
many emissions because manufacturing
emissions are not um included in a lot
of the kind of statistics that are used
which means that the people who the kind
of where our stuff is made is not being
included there's a lot of like creative
accounting that happens that makes it
look like the uk is much better than it
actually is and instead blames these
countries where we actually get a lot of
the stuff in our lives from and so i
think that whilst the uk is
going against the advice of the
international energy agency on approving
saying that we shouldn't be approving
any new oil and gas fields we shouldn't
be approving any new fossil fuels and
they're still trying to improve the
cambodia oil field along with 39 other
oil gas and coal projects they cannot
say that they are walking the walk that
is absolutely ridiculous and i really
kind of sympathize with people who feel
like these are maybe new year's um like
resolutions that aren't going to be kept
to you and i think that's why it's
important for people power to keep our
governments accountable
um cristiano i'm not going to ask you to
adjudicate on
a british argument but liz was really
raising the question about whether all
governments have really
been consistent in what
they said compared to what they have
done
what do you think has happened since you
negotiate that agreement in paris have
governments really delivered on what
they said they deliver on
well sadly i would say it is
mostly the countries of the north of the
global north that have not delivered on
their promises especially on supporting
developing countries with the necessary
finance that is necessary for those
countries to be able to make the
transition that is important to them but
also to the rest of the world the uh the
the most painful example of that is the
famous hundred billion that were
promised years ago uh and they were
supposed to 2012 right
yes and they were supposed to be flowing
by 2020. and here we are at the end of
2021 and we know that this is going to
go into 2022 at least so we already know
that there will be at least a three-year
delay so that is uh it is very
concerning that you can add to other
things so i think one very
understandable conclusion that is
reached by many is that
trust has been broken trust has been
breached at the same time
we have to understand that this is not
either
the vision of i don't know a satanic
vision nor an angelic vision this is not
perfection and this is not disaster this
is a transition and all transitions are
messy
by definition so i think depending on
the glasses that you want to put on you
can go out there and you can argue like
allegra just argued everything that she
says is actually part of the reality and
what michaela has just said is also part
of the reality that's the difficulty
that we have all right that we have to
be able to manage
different realities in equal standing
thank you christian let's um
let's accept christiana's point that
this isn't
going to be black and white i think
that's unrealistic but let's see what
lens our wall has on what lens our
viewers panels have on the extent to
which people are optimistic
who agrees with liz
that the promises that have been made
generally speaking have not been
delivered
those who agree with
liz
i think that it's pretty
that is pretty much the majority of
people who think that there's been a gap
between what's been said and what's been
delivered alexander downer
governments haven't really
done the job
from our uh our
audience here
well um whatever the audience thing
thinks will be influenced by what the
media reports so let's just think about
this for a minute
in relation to my own country australia
we made commitments going back to the
kyoto protocol in the late 1990s and we
fulfilled all those commitments in paris
we made a commitment to reduce our
emissions by 26 to 28 by
2030 we will exceed that we'll reduce
our emissions by 35 percent by then
because that's a forecast what we've
done so far since 2005
is reduce our emissions by 20
now let me make one other point
it is
incredibly challenging for any
government
to on the one hand address the climate
change issue which they need to and
reduce emissions on the other hand make
sure people are not plunged into poverty
into darkness or suffer in any other way
it is hugely challenging
and i think many western governments i
think i do think the british government
certainly the australian government i
think the americans are doing quite a
good job are trying to get this balance
right the australian government
has has
more than exceeded
the commitments that it made
and it has made including in paris
so um you know i think we we obviously
in different countries have to meet our
commitments in different ways because
our economies are all structured in
completely different ways what you do in
australia is not relevant to the uk or
belgium or california we're all
different so we have to have the
flexibility to work out ways of getting
co2 emissions michaela
be realistic i think i mean you're being
you're being asked to be realistic now
i think this is absolutely ludicrous and
actually quite insulting to a lot of
small iron states that um it's being
made out that um the australian
government is doing so much when
australia is not trying to phase out
fossil fuels at all there doesn't seem
to be any plans really for that in in
the this time we actually need it to
happen and also i think it really
frustrates me talk about this as if it
is a debate between
as if it's an equal debate between like
either protecting people's lives and
stopping people from being plugged into
poverty or attacking the climate crisis
because the reality is is that the
climate crisis will cause so much harm
and destruction all around the world if
we do not tackle it adequately and so
that should be the priority but not only
that but if we actually have governments
in power and people in power and
policies that prioritize justice within
this transition then we can actually
create a better world for all of us
where we don't have a lot of the issues
that we currently have now it's not just
about stopping the bad stuff it's also
about starting good things as well all
right alexander
well i mean the australian government
has met its commitments and it's
exceeded its commitment so continual
assertions and attacks on the australian
government aren't going to change the
facts and the facts are that australia
is doing very well now the problem
the problem is that australia's starting
point was very different from other
countries as one of the gr the world's
great energy and resource exporters and
of course australian exports have helped
to drive the reduction in poverty in
countries like china japan south korea
and so on but we all recognize we've got
to do something to reduce co2 emissions
and there has to be a transition to low
emission energy and countries like
australia are making a major effort to
do that all right i don't think it's
fair to say we're insulting to our
neighbours australia does more for the
countries of the pacific islands than
almost any other
or and i could go further than any other
country on earth in assisting those
countries we could spend a long time on
that but i want to come back to our wall
um i'm going to talk to ron knox because
i i've noticed that ron um
good evening again uh ron i gather that
uh you're a bit skeptical about what
you're hearing
why
i'm skeptical because
i don't know what it will take for the
world to finally wake up what
catastrophe needs to happen before the
world finally wakes up to what's going
on here
and what i'm seeing is
a lack of political will to make the
necessary changes to provide the
necessary finance that's going to make a
difference
and that political will
will only come from people
right we've already seen how
minds can change when people force that
change
and to me this is the most classic issue
of where
political
will
will be generated and indeed controlled
by the will of the people you take us on
to
the next part piece of ground i want to
explore which is
whether politicians would have gone as
far as they did without pressure from
activists or are the likes of michaela
and greta sondberg really leading the
way that's coming up next
[Applause]
[Applause]
is runaway climate change inevitable
despite the agreement struck in glasgow
that's this week's topic on the great
debate
and would we be even further adrift
without the relentless strident and
often angry protests from activists
let's go to the walls to go to our
viewers panel and talk to farah khan
good evening again pharah thank you for
joining us um
what's your thought about this the
impact of activists
activists and especially young activists
are doing all that they can to create
and protest for climate attraction but
my question is when will world leaders
take the future seriously and will it be
too late how many cops do we need before
humanity goes extinct
well okay we're going to put that
question to the panel in a moment but i
first want to talk to another viewer uh
jason mcgilvray and um jason
i think i'm right in saying that you
were actually one of those
activists who were protesting uh in
glasgow is that right
yes i was um i felt driven to go to it
um just in the current climate crisis
and um i feel that we we aren't doing
enough i mean [ __ ] 26 to me seems like a
bit of a cop out um i believe we should
be doing more
uh
the targets are there we've got maybe a
decade maybe more or less uh we're not
we're not hitting the targets quick
enough you know um it's easy enough for
all these talking shots to take place
and they all fly in but unless they're
actually doing stuff on the ground
unless they're getting the big players
involved like china india and then
it's a bit of a talking shop you know
that's it you know let's bring it back
into studio a question that pharah has
asked is when will world leaders start
to take climate crisis
seriously allegra you
can hear the authentic furious voice of
youth did it make the blindest bit of
difference in the negotiations that were
going on of course it does it it it's
it's it
keeps the pressure up it reminds
everybody of what it's all about if if
indeed they needed needed reminding but
the
the thing i would like to take issue
with this the idea that cop 26 was a
talking shop
i understand why people feel that
summits in general are but i personally
don't think that cop 26 was one because
you saw actually
real world commitments being wrung out
of other countries and and a couple of
really critical things as well as the
real world commitments on coal cars cash
and trees but you also one of the
critical things that has come out this
weekend is the finalization of the paris
agreement and there's three areas in
which that's the case but one of them is
on transparency so now in the future we
will have clear indicators of each and
every country and where they're going
where they're on track and where they're
not i get what you're saying but uh to
be honest uh you can't see it but uh
there's a couple of people on um the
wall who are going blah blah blah
whatever
you think is happening it isn't
necessarily cutting through to the
people you need to convince which
look
you know
i understand why people think summits in
general are blah blah blah but do they
think that getting every single country
in the world to agree to face down coal
is is blah blah blah do they would they
rather us not have had that in the
document okay christiana
what do you think
does the the protest i mean it you know
it makes for us it's fantastic when i
say us journalists and television
producers and whatnot great pictures
does it make any difference to what
actually happens in the room when those
decisions are being made
it does make a difference as allegra
said it definitely keeps up the pressure
but it is one of the pressure points i
think we have to see this much more
holistically first of all science
that is where policy needs to be very
firmly grounded so the pressure from
scientists has been incredibly helpful
the fact that they're screaming from the
rooftops has been very
very helpful then you have the youth
activists that are also grounded on
science on top of that you have the
forces of the market because the fact is
that the technologies that are the
solutions to climate change are now much
more accessible and becoming much
cheaper than legacy technologies on top
of that you have growing litigation and
companies are getting much more
concerned on top of that you have some
leading companies that have understood
that it is in their interest to
decarbonize and finally you have
changing customer demand so it's not
about one pressure point it's about
stacking all of this together and that
is actually what moves governments
forward mikayla i want to put one
question to you about all of this i'm
guessing that you are on the side of
pharah and jason who think that the
activists the demonstrations made a big
difference
when they were making that decision
because we watched it happening live on
the floor on saturday evening to go from
phasing out cold to phasing down coal no
number of demonstrations and placards
could have stopped that happening
could it i
i think that it definitely could i think
that we've seen with history yep but i'm
saying that like the more people that we
have behind a movement the more change
you see happens and that's why we need
even more people behind this movement
than have currently been part of it
because the more people we have the more
impact we'll have throughout history
we've seen that change isn't this
passive thing things don't just get
better like out of nowhere they get
better because people force them to be
that way and that's why i think that if
we had even more campaigning around
especially around oil and gas and other
fossil fuels because i think so often in
this conversation
india and china are being used as a
scapegoat for this they're being used as
a scapegoat for the issue around phase
down and phase out when actually
if they've been inclusion of all fossil
fuels which would include nations like
the uk like um eu governments like the
us who are actually more dependent upon
oil and gas than they are of coal
then that would have been a kind of
agreement with encompassing all these
countries right we'll keep that thought
in mind because after the break we're
going to be asking should the developed
world have done more to persuade other
countries to give up on fossil fuels
[Applause]
[Applause]
this is the great debate and this week
we're assessing the cop 26 climate
conference and asking is runaway climate
change now inevitable
a crucial stumbling block at the talks
was the issue of adaptation finance
that's the money promised by rich
countries to help poor countries out
cutting missions and that was something
that our viewers panel wanted to talk
about too so i'm going to
go to david young david you are in
northampton what's your thought on this
first of all trevor thank you for the
opportunity to be able to be on the
program and really at least have a voice
in this argument
look
i really think that we can talk all day
about green industrial revolution
we are thousands of miles away from
people that are dying
it's okay for that politician in
australia or our politician boris in
england
or any one of us to say you know well
that's okay we're gonna have 20 years
now these people are dying
197 countries were at that summit
and i watched every single day with you
guys on sky the point of the matter is
here look
what is our responsibility
to developing countries
that face immediate climate consequences
okay
thank you very much david to our studio
panel
uh that question from david again
what is our responsibility to developing
countries that face immediate
climate consequences
alexander
well i think we all have a
responsibility to humanity to do what we
can to address this issue just to put it
in context
since 2005 emissions in china have
increased by around
80 percent and emissions in india by
around 70
whereas emissions in western countries
have actually declined
so
the challenge i mean given the huge size
of china's economy the challenge is to
see what can be done to get china's
emissions down
now you can't order the communist
government in china to reduce its
emissions you can only
do what you can to persuade them to do
that um and i think to be honest with
you um
through cop 26 but through diplomacy
over quite some years some progress is
being made to do that the hundred
billion um dollars is designed to help
finance adaptation policies in
developing countries but you know how do
you spend a hundred billion dollars you
don't just give somebody a hundred
billion dollar check that has to be
accountability and transparency and how
the money is spent if you know what i
mean yes um and it has to be it has to
be done carefully so that takes time but
i think developed countries are
are prepared to pay but remember
throughout all of this process
throughout all of this process no
government is going to ruin
its own economy in addressing this issue
it's not going to ruin it and put people
out of work and destroy the structure of
their own society they're not going to
do that and that needs to be understood
in this debate um
christiana figueres
what alexander downer says
is realistic isn't it i mean
we can say that this is a kind of
selfishness and so on but
governments get elected to look after
their own people
yes but south africa is actually a
pretty compelling case because number
one it has
the highest solar rooftop penetration in
the world uh it has one of the highest
concentrated solar potentials in the
world it has probably because of where
it is geographically it can easily
become the number one producer and
exporter of green hydrogen so it's not
like australia doesn't have an option
the fact that for example just to come
just to compare south africa which does
have a policy to move out of coal was
able to secure 8.5 billion dollars to
transition out of coal at cop26 proves
the difference if you have a policy that
you understand coal is actually the root
of all poverty and of much disease
around the world and you commit to
transitioning out of it you will get
support for it if you hang on to a a
fuel that was great in the past century
but has no place in this century well
you're digging your own grave okay
alexander i guess i'm going to give you
the chance to respond to that
yeah well australia is transitioning out
of uh coal-fired power stations incl and
increasingly to gas and using wind and
and solar power it's invest the
government has been investing 20 billion
dollars between now and 2030
in um
in new technologies particularly
hydrogen and solar technologies i mean i
don't okay everything is being done
which realistically could be done and
then and you know australia runs
australia runs a great deal better than
south africa and people's living
standards are better in australia than
south africa
doing too bad a job a legal strategy i
don't want to get too as fun as it might
be for us brits to to to talk about
australia all the time don't want to get
stuck on one country isn't there an
issue here that
number one the rich countries taken
overall
haven't really done
what they said and they certainly
haven't done what some of the poor
countries want the hundred billion that
christiana figures mentioned earlier
hasn't turned up
and on top of that
isn't the problem here that the biggest
emitters china and india seem to get off
scot-free from criticism
lots of questions there trevor um
firstly on the 100 billion the the pm
and alex sharma
have not hidden the fact that it is of
deep regret in fact it's it's it's in
it's in the
the glasgow pack that i've got here it's
there in black and white you know it's a
regret a disappointment to us that we
didn't get but they all promised it 12
years ago still isn't happened hold on a
second it will be hit in 2023 that is
late and for countries on the front line
if we listen to the marshall islands or
tuvalu and so on they are they are
already uh seeing
parts of their land go underwater so
this is here already for them it's not
something that happens in the future so
we have acknowledged that all the way
through no point in dressing that up it
is late but even so when you get to 2023
it does start to go up
quickly and over the 100 billion and
over the point 21 to 25 it's more than
500 billion so it's essentially a
problem of of back loaded money i'm not
trying to get away from the fact that it
will be hit late it's just that the
money is coming
um and then there's a there's a second
point which isn't so much about money
but it's more about technology and about
spreading
good lower carbon tech and that's one of
the parts that the prime minister and
alex sharma feel is so exciting about
this place that we find ourselves in now
and to your point about the duty that
the rich world has to those places that
are struggling
there is that recognition from the prime
minister he talked about that in his
opening ceremony speech we do have a
responsibility and that is to share all
of this technology coming up do we all
have to change how we live and what
should we do
we'll be discussing that with the film
director richard curtis founder of the
make my money matter campaign
[Applause]
is runaway climate change inevitable
and what should we all do to try to
prevent it
let's talk to jim dale jim you're in
high wickham you've got an idea i think
good evening uh trevor yes and the panel
as well um first i should first admit
that i that uh i've got a uh an
intrinsic interest in this particularly
i've been i'm a meteorologist and i've
been a meteorologist for the last 30 odd
years surely the focus is well now
the the titanic has hit the iceberg the
iceberg is sinking and the titanic has
got burning debt chairs that we're
moving around while it sinks at the same
time if you get my drift that's what's
basically at me so the focus now has got
to be on
particularly on on how we uh how how the
world really
faces up to the consequences of the last
30 years of doing not a lot
okay
what have you got out of that for our
panel here
sorry when
well i want to ask the panel how they
see the world preparing for the
consequences the impact consequences of
a rise of more than a couple of degrees
and probably more than that uh in in
time to come what's what's the what's
the world now doing to prepare for that
um in terms of the the catastrophes that
are likely to to unfold
okay well jim's got a pretty apocalyptic
question there how is the world
preparing for the consequences of a rise
of more than two degrees
before i want to put that to
our other guests i want to
talk to richard curtis the film director
who is in los angeles who's actually
um got some thoughts about the way that
people can prepare
perhaps to
avert that catastrophe good evening
richard um hi travis goodwin what is
what is your view about this what can we
do
well look i think uh you know this is
such an interesting discussion and i
think that it's great that everybody
acknowledges you know that we are on a
war footing and when you're on a war
footing everybody has to do their part
and i'm very interested in what we as
individuals you know can do how we can
use our money and particularly affect
business so i'm obsessed by pensions
there's 3.1 trillion in the world
pension partner a lot of us have got
money still in businesses that are in
deforestation arms uh old style fossil
fuels and we all have the power to go
into work tomorrow and say
has our company changed its pension into
a sustainable pension you know that's
the biggest chunk of money that we've
got so all these personal things in
terms of buying sustainable foods
getting renewable energy changing our
flights i think all of us every single
day
have to not as it were we should put and
demand a lot of politicians but we're
all part of it and we can do positive
stuff ourselves and there's a consumer
revolution going on and businesses are
starting to change they've got to
accelerate that change the public can
help them accelerate that change the
governments will listen to businesses as
much as they ever listen to protesters
so i just wonder as it were be part of
it and i think we have to try and be
part of it every day so the idea is that
actually people would use the money that
they put into pensions in some way shape
or form to essentially contribute to
reforestation uh mitigation schemes and
so on i suppose
exactly you've got to find private money
as it were invested money which will go
into the most interesting new
technologies into the firms that are
doing the most on gender race climate
all these kind of things and we have
that simple power actually there's a
brilliant uh australian uh uh pension
company called uh my future super which
has been doing this so we can all have
some particular effect and i don't think
we mustn't feel powerless we've got to
be on the streets but we've also got to
be coming and the first thing we can do
is make sure that our money isn't
supporting the bad things but is
supporting the good things i suppose
some some people might say that's all
very well it's very nice but actually
number one the scale of the challenge is
way way beyond what
we can do even with our
pensions and anyway don't we elect
people to solve these problems rather
than us having to do this kind of thing
well no that's where we've got to be
really imaginative because you say the
scale but actually we've been part of
shifting 900 billion pounds in the last
two years into businesses that support
sustainability so that is an enormous
amount of money and also you know the
government is part of this we're
actually making trying to ask the
government to mandate that pensions
actually pay attention to climate things
and demand transparency so it's all part
of that interaction between us as people
who spend our money and drive the
economy and the government policies that
reflect that and businesses changing
their behavior so it shouldn't be i mean
sometimes it has to be us and them but
often our behaviors personally can shift
the economics of the world we are
looking at a kind of revolution in
consumer behavior and indeed in
capitalism and we've got to be part of
it rather than just waiting for it to
happen okay um allegra
an actual idea are you writing that down
and taking it to the prime minister
tomorrow suffice it to say uh i am well
aware of richard curtis's work and the
brilliant campaigning of make my money
matter um because i think i'm surprised
you didn't say it richard that it's i
think it's been
some studies show that
asking tough questions of where your
pension is invested is probably the most
effective thing you can do
he's nodding his head so it's it's it's
off the charts effective if you want to
change your carbon footprint uh in in
the most meaningful way
michaela loach
of everybody who's in this discussion
you probably um are going to have the
biggest pension fund because you're
going to be saving longer than the rest
of us
is this an idea that you think is
practical worthwhile is this the a
pathway to change for you i mean i
definitely think that divestment is a
huge thing that we can do so moving our
money away from the bad stuff like so
many banks in the uk currently invest in
fossil fuels like hsb barclays all the
main banks they all invest in fossil
fuels loads of pension funds also invest
in fossil fuels that's a huge way that
we can actually move that money and move
that and kind of demand away from there
because
in many ways the money does have an
impact on them um i also really just
want to actually touch on what was said
before about um adaptation and um
climate finance because i think there
was a quite dangerous um kind of idea
being spread as if um the country
countries in the west and will just be
completely destroyed if they have to
give any money back to the countries
that have been historically harmed i'm
from jamaica jamaica has experienced
colonial violence historically from the
uk and it's currently being submerged by
water because of rising sea levels that
are being caused by emissions that are
being emitted out in the uk and other um
countries like it we have an opportunity
actually that we could also like aid
those countries like jamaica and other
countries that are also low-lying states
in being able to adapt and also and
prepare for this but also just to stop
this from happening in the first place
and actually create a better world for
all of us in the uk we can provide jobs
we can and provide safe housing we have
those policies already and that
technology we have to do it perhaps
all right um
there's a lot of agreement to that point
but i want to stay for the moment with
richard's idea about how
individuals can make a difference um
australia got a good write up there
alexander
there's nothing wrong with um
superannuation funds as they're called
in australia pension funds um investing
their money in uh green technologies of
course and um it sounds great and i'm in
principle in favor of it however i would
say two things about finance first of
all you do want to make sure
if you're running a pension fund that
you're running it profitably otherwise
you will not be able to pay out the
pensions eventually so just be a bit
careful
um with too much virtue signaling
secondly
to divest
it's quite part we'll come to you in a
second richard quite popular
well i'm sure these green investments
are hugely profitable and that would be
very good um it's quite popular to say
that pension funds and other
institutions should sell out
of fossil fuel companies the thing is
they are selling out and those
assets are being purchased in particular
by private hedge funds who
because of recent very big increases in
energy prices have made a huge amount of
money so you know you need to think
these things through and think about the
finance not just be virtue signaling
okay richard curtis uh your virtue
signaling and by the way putting your
hands in
uh putting yourself in the hands of um
some ghastly capitalists
well wait a minute virtue signaling
that's that by the way
virtue signaling is is really that is
completely the wrong term for moving
your money to support the best new
businesses i mean that is
an atrocious way to treat it and
sustainable and ethical pensions are
doing as well if not better i mean i've
checked this with every single bank i've
talked to mark carney about it it's just
not true that's an old-fashioned truth
and shift things have shifted really
over the last five years and this is a
positive serious way of doing it the
issue of divestment is a very
interesting one but it's not a black or
white thing and you'll find the pensions
are really looking at which oil
companies are doing the most and they're
supporting those most and they will most
thrive and the public will most support
them i i really think this is a serious
discussion about the use of money about
making our financial footprint affect
our carbon footprint and not a token
thing at all people's pensions are the
biggest chunk of money they've got and
they should be using that as
intelligently as well informed with the
best with the best pension companies
that they can to make a difference to
the world and make those businesses
thrive and improve the economy through
those thriving businesses okay i want to
come back to the wall and talk to um
somebody who's talked to before is a
small businessman robin gillingham um
you're a small business owner in devon
we talked before about taxes and so on
what do you make of this proposal where
are you
uh
are you with richard curtis on this
um i think um i mean everybody's got a
point of view and it all it generally
makes sense um first of all i wanted to
say that cop 26 i think has been a good
success it's brought the world together
it's also been a good platform for the
activists to have their say
um and obviously it's created great
awareness for the challenges that we
face um obviously there's a frustration
with the lack of action or the perceived
lack of action
um from the corporations and
subsequently world leaders um but i
think we've got to be frank we do live
in a capitalist society uh majority of
us and that obviously is now literally
ruling the waves um so if the world
leaders cannot enforce change or if it's
not being perceived as being quick
enough then maybe consumers should take
it into their own hands and uh take it
upon themselves and basically to live a
more sustainable lifestyle
and let's lead the way
cristiano for guerras you've um
been fighting
this particular fight for much longer
than most
um what do you where are you on this
can we turn
our savings to good use in this respect
but we have to it's the only prudent
thing to do i definitely don't want to
have my savings in stranded assets
meaning that not only am i doing a crime
against humanity
but i'm actually losing the value of my
hard-earned money and the fact is as
richard has already pointed out the fact
is that the finance sector as a whole
has woken up to realize that if they
want to protect the value of their
portfolios they have to move over so in
glasgow we had
450 financial institutions from 45
countries with over 130 trillion dollars
in assets across all the major segments
of the finance sector including asset
owners asset managers insurers
commercial banks investment consultants
stock exchanges credit rating agencies
everyone saying we are going to net zero
so let me come back to
the wall and put to you
where we are we started this
conversation asking whether
it's inevitable
that runaway climate change has gone
past the point of no return i want to
see where you now stand
can i see that hands who believe that we
can hearing what you've heard we can
slow it down those who think that we
still have the possibility of slowing
down climate change
and i think i'm seeing quite an
optimistic return there and
uh
some seeing something 50 50 60
looks to me
actually more than that who think that
we can do something about this that's
all we have time for this evening and uh
it just remained for me to say thank you
to our panelists tonight alexander
downer
allegra stratton
michaela loach
christiana fergueris and of course
richard curtis
and of course i want to say thank you to
our viewers panel as robust and in there
as ever
we're waving goodbye to you thank you so
much
and of course thanks to you at home for
watching keep the debate going keep
talking
that was the great debate
[Applause]
you